in California there was businesses that  that were padlocked there was  restaurants that were shut down there  was there was businesses that had  electricity cut by the city because they  dared to defy their arbitrary lockdown  orders meanwhile Walmart was allowed to  be open Costco was allowed to be open  all these big box stores with  connections to politicians they were  able to to run their businesses police  officers came on Grandma's door knocked  it down because she dared to keep her  business open even when she had an  online business the stories that  happened here in the United States  should terrify people because it  highlights the story of or of order  followers doing what they're told  committing human rights violations  against the people of this country